the gyro can experience think with
Burton birf that okay we want to do a
show think of the 80s or 90s you'd have
to pitch it to network right have them
approve it
yeah they bring in riders you're looking
at how long would that take to evolve
into a legit show there's a green light
then get a pilot then test well yeah no
no chance yeah we'd also people would
start [ __ ] with it they would come in
burn I want you to address different I
want you to address I want you to once
like Sinatra I see you people taking you
more seriously if you were gonna save
custom too much bird can you tone it
down you seem aggressive imagine if I
went to a production company and said
yeah what I want to do is like smoke
weed and talk about [ __ ] and say things
I don't really mean but I think it's
funny at the time that I regret it and
I'm gonna drink a lot oh no we're gonna
air the fight we're gonna smoke weed and
we're gonna talk [ __ ] but but also I'm
gonna have presidential candidates and
really sick show and scientists and me a
guy with brain damage I'm gonna debate
it important to everybody back out of
this office well when Brian and I were
up Fox they they want to make it a TV
show like a legit TV show remember that
Mouse dude dude I remember when they
were telling you to not curse yes and I
was like get out now I remember yelling
at you they're like vampires they're
trying to bite you trying to turn you
remember me and Brian in that meeting
cost and I was like this is what but
meanwhile they liked you because of who
you were before they came along and
before they came along you were cussing
and then they want to do a sport they
didn't know what to do is then I went do
a sport show us then they brought me in
and go they go they go so we know what
to find the kid what if we really what
if we replays Brian count with Michael
Rapaport
no yep they want to get rid of Brian
mmm-hmm Wow it's because he's all
because of his Erica because it's all
and you just talk [ __ ] or what is it the
way a dress is because I can fix that
that's great what a bunch of dummies
this is this is great let's [ __ ] it up
and this thing that I really like let's
ruin it but then
they're like wait they're making how
much money and we'd signed no no no so I
hate next year the deals up in December
we're gonna need half and I went oh
that's not happening
all right well December is your last
last month and I think we're in October
I go that's fine we're gonna go do our
own thing and take all the money then
okay and then I never forget this goes I
don't wanna hear about the second
podcast just write out December and I
went I can't do that did I yell at the
listener no I'm leaving he was don't do
that
no all right cool next day I go on the
pike so so in December our contracts up
still in half our [ __ ] I tried going
back the next day and with their
security out front they wouldn't let me
in Rios my last day at Fox yeah really
yep then we just start doing it random
way back well that's the real clear
changing of the guard
we're that old-school mentality they
think that they own the talent they
think they owned you the idea that they
think they have 50% just that but what
are you doing what are you doing the guy
gets another freaking this guy gets in
my face cast the guy gets in my face I
don't say his name he goes just how you
have your black belt in fighting on my
black belt in the entertainment team I
would I would fall on the ground and
start curling up in a fetal position
laughs does it have no idea what you're
referring to believe know how to rob
people out of the percentage that they
really deserve what are you bringing to
that's I thought I went fit if you can
show me why you guys did a 50% I'll give
you 50 go here's what's our studio you
know Fox it Fox gives you the platform
no no no hold up we had a platform
before even got here I can do this up
the street when you get more views dude
what no why would you get 50% there's a
guy I don't know man there's no reason I
had a guy not that long ago asked for
50% of my podcast to be a part of a
network not that long ago yeah my years
ago maybe I don't say what are you
talking about 50%
well even now like certain comics want
to start podcasts go hey this network
podcast woman came to me they want 50%
but they give me this - I want no no
stop stop don't do that do it yourself
that's a weird number like you're you're
pretending that they couldn't do
out you if you want 50% 50% is like if
you and me right if it's the Brendan and
Joe show
what kind of has to be 50% cuz it's both
of us right so it's like there's two of
us
yes so you're part show umph our show we
need each other with the Guerra together
should be 50% then we're friends it
should be good 2% but we could do it
with Tom the producer or we could do
with Steve the network you this isn't
you guys don't matter so you can't have
50% maybe you should definitely deserve
something 5050 is crazy it's insane
that's crazy
that's a crazy number that means you're
saying I couldn't do without you that
does that doesn't make any sense but
that's what they used to do with TV
shows you got to realize if you're
thinking about Hawaii five-o like the
production company has a deal with the
network and they put it together and
everybody gets paid and the people that
are putting it on television have a
giant chunk of that that's the studio
executives networking seconds you go to
their houses their big [ __ ] parties
dude I'd go to some of their houses man
they'd have parties and you'd be like
wow these guys all in but what are they
doing what are they doing well they're
they're taking your stuff and they're
the critical mechanism that is necessary
to get you on television
well now the world is television our
heads are through the [ __ ] holes and
now we're looking out this open air
there's no need for someone to take 50%
anymore knowing that people don't give a
[ __ ] it's on Fox HP they don't see
always operated and those those those
fans those subscribers or whatever
network they're gonna follow me if I'm
here if I'm here they here they don't
get it though these guys went through
the Fox system people went through the
ABC system they went through the CBS
system and in if they were in that
system 20 years ago this was the system
the system's you make deals you put
together shows you're getting it on the
air it's cooler
you're giving me you're giving your very
valuable it's a very important thing to
if you got on CBS back in you know 2000
change it was a very important thing so
it made sense the deal made sense but it
doesn't make sense on the Internet
the Internet is everybody's it's like
everybody has a CBS like these gentlemen
who
made that video on the coronavirus they
they they don't have a network they
don't need they don't need it all it has
to do is get to one of these
[Applause]